Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the
Monday morning podcast for Monday.
Um, December 30th, 2013 all my God,
it's the last Monday of 2013.
You guys,
um,
I'm actually still enjoying the holidays.
I don't know about you
guys usually buy the,
at this point I'm so fucking sick of
everything and I do mean everything then
I'm kinda like,
I almost excited to go back to work.
But this year has been a great thing.
Other than seeing that
fucking have yourself a merry
little Christmas commercial,
like 58 fucking times.
Every God damn hockey game,
you know,
or that one with the Douche who who
he's got a family right already.
He's hateable,
you know.
Oh is that your little fucking
fake television family?
You know,
that didn't notice the film crew watching
you guys having a Christmas and he
makes the home videos and
everybody fucking gets around,
you know the TV and they're all
tearing up. Whoa. What a set amount.
A little sad thing you made were
crying because we are so happy.
Right?
Nobody trashes them
cause I'm a little sensitive little pussy.
Something homophobic,
like it would really go down.
Now everybody is tolerant
of this fuck and his little,
uh,
always that movie with the chick,
with the Rose pedals coming
down on her tits, right or that,
and the kids film in the trash
and nobody understood a man.
That's who he should have been,
you know,
getting shot in the garage.
Whatever the fuck happened.
Something happened in the garage,
then somebody gets shot. You know,
I thought it was a little on
the nose that the hard ass guy,
I'm cross the street was gay.
You know that whole thing that people
who hate gay people, it's secretly,
secretly because they're gay.
You know what I mean?
I'm not saying it doesn't happen,
but I mean people who hate the al Qaeda
is that cause they're secretly the al
Qaeda. Well, it metaphorically
speaking maybe, oh, gives a fuck.
I don't need to see the commercial
anymore. That's all I'm saying.
Is that all you say? Oh, I take it
is I think that's what I'm saying.
You want to start an argument
and ruin my fucking holiday week.
I just told you consummate a good
mood. What more do I have to do? Um,
with holidays,
with the holidays comes family members,
dude.
Um, the reason why this podcast is extra
latest one cause I'm on vacation and I
don't give a fuck. You
know, I don't give a fuck.
All right. I'm trying to work, but it's
a half day for me too. Just like if you,
if you, if you've asshole boss made you
come in today to do the end of the year
spreadsheets, whatever the
hell you got to do. Right.
And all you're hearing is fucking
a bowl game music and you had,
I understand you. That's where,
that's where I'm at. Okay.
So why don't I do a little longer podcasts
this week and help you limp through
your fucking half day.
You know the, you know,
you're the only port Basta that's
in the office right now. You know,
the boss trying to make you
feel like you're special.
I'll tell you only brought
my best employees today.
Then you six,
or at the top of the list of people that
I knew were in debt just far enough and
we'll raise just well enough to
not tell me to go fuck myself.
So that's why I asked you six.
I was wrong about the other two.
Um, so anyways, um, I couldn't do
the podcast today because I have a,
you know,
some relatives over here crashing with
me and I don't have a podcast studio
except for the all things
comedy podcast studio,
but I don't wanna use that when I
interview people. I'm like Dave Techno,
FIFA, miss that one. Um, other than
that, it just do what my fucking house.
So all my shit's downstairs.
You know,
one of my cousins is asleep downstairs.
I got the shit in there.
I don't want to wake them
up or whatever. So, uh,
I'm also doing my end of the year shit,
what I have to get all my
paperwork together, you know,
to make sure all the i's are dotted all
the t's across to make sure a February
there's a knock on the door from those
cons who were on the legal side of
stealing come up to me and say,
Oh,
do you have your paperwork so we can
take this money from you and then do
whatever the fuck we want
with it. You know? So, um,
I've been avoiding doing this,
but over the years of paperwork has
just gotten too big. And I went down,
this is what I did this morning.
Okay. During my vacation,
I drove down to staples and
I bought a file cabinet.
I gotta tell you it was a
okay
if you two wasn't playing over the
speakers, and thank God for you too,
by the way,
that somehow something of that level
of quality can actually seep into the,
uh, the, the whatever, the, the, the
place selection at a fucking office Max.
You know,
it's brilliant,
but they can still be that
uplifting yet still be pop.
And still be played in a department store.
That was the only thing keeping me
going cause a fucking soul crushing.
I don't know what it is about buying a
file cabinet and I don't want to hear any
countries, the Oh first
world problems. You know,
you might have fucking people who've
never left the first world and don't even
know anything about the fucking third
world other than what the fuck they see on
TV, which is basically some fucking
reporter with an army helmet on,
standing and we're trying to get to,
we're trying to get more bambot and
have a fucking wealth built. I mean,
what do you know about the third world
before you tell me that before you lean
over your potato skins and a
fuck an Applebee's, you know,
and act like you're appreciating your,
your fucking lot in life.
You're eating potato skins.
Okay? They should be doing that.
The third world,
if they have nothing to live for,
stick that down your throat and
have a fucking heart attack.
Here you are living in the fucking best
goddamn situation she can possibly be in.
And what are you doing? Huh? You're
draining the oil out of your ass.
Sorry. So I go there. Yeah. Um, and,
and one the people too who I think even
used that expression first world problem,
didn't even know what it means.
They just heard enough people say
it and then they get a just, Oh,
you kind of say it during this part of
a conversation. I do that all the time.
I have all kinds of words in the English
language that I could not give you a
definition of,
but I could use perfectly in a sentence
cause I heard enough other people doing
it.
You know,
it's like all those people who can do
Michael Jackson's fucking leg kick with
the loafer, you know, can they go beyond
that? No, but they can do that part.
They've seen that park has, yeah,
they've seen that enough. Right.
Okay. But if you notice when they walk
down the street and out of the fucking
sidewalks lighten up. And that's
what I'm, that's my point.
If you can't do the fucking math on
that, then right. Get help. Yeah. Um,
so I go into this staples and,
uh, it was a good youtube song.
It wasn't one of their douchey ones.
Like beautiful day.
They fucking start slowing it
up. Good. I can fucking relax.
And then all of a sudden
Bano starts screaming at me.
What a beautiful day it is.
It's like, yeah, it was a beautiful day
until you started fucking screaming at me.
Why don't you tell the edge to take it
down to Larry to get off the fucking
crash cymbal? Maybe ride on a fucking
high hit, maybe take out the brushes,
get off. Um, anyway,
so I walk in there and
these are my selections.
There's either a, the staples. Okay.
First of all,
you hit,
you have the company that all we do
is we make file cabinets. All right?
And they have this fucking bandaid
beige four drawer fucking file cabinet,
you know?
Okay.
I just looked at it and
I, my, you know, I just,
I just stuff just felt something in
my chest just gave way. You know,
I think it was hope. Some
former hope. I Dunno.
Something like say I live 80 years,
you know,
I would've lived 80 years and a half
a day if I didn't do what I did this
morning. You know what I mean? I really,
I've been, and I believe that shit too.
I think anytime you're doing something
in life that you don't want to be doing,
I think that adds up. And
the other rent, you know,
you would have been 90 but in the end of
your life you die at 82 because if you
add up all those fucking moments
of going into staples, you know,
or we need batteries and standing in
line at the fucking drug store with the
skeleton shift yet.
Oh.
And there's nobody there to fucking unlock
God damn thing to get you the fucking
batteries. You've got to wait
till the fucking lines down.
So the chick behind the register and come,
all of that shit ends up adding
up to like eight and a half
years I your life. And that's
just trying to buy shit. You know?
Forget about if you're a living with
the wrong person. Oh. Speaking of which,
not to fucking,
not to air the dirty
laundry of my neighborhood.
That I got to tell you something.
All My neighbors,
I lucked out fucking great people,
but I got to have like three,
three doors up the fucking
street is this older couple.
I don't know how old they are. They
sound like they've been together forever,
but they, the width of the energy they
have when they scream at each other,
I still think they're
in their 50s you know,
like they got one more big contract
they can ask for four years.
You know, life's only going to give him
three and then they're gonna fucking,
they're gonna move to Seattle,
like can know. Right. So
when they yell at each other,
I swear to God.
Yeah.
The, the, the,
I can't even the hate the fucking
bile when they yell at each other,
like they are so done with each other.
I see.
Every time there's a pause in
the argument, bye. He says,
fuck. I'm like, the
fuck. I can't even do it.
It's like,
it's not quite blood curdling scream.
Yeah.
And it's not quite just
like maniacal rage.
It's somewhere between the two.
Yeah.
That the only way you can duplicate it
as if you have that sort of pain in your
heart and they scream at each other and
every time they pause when there's that
pause, I've just, I went cause
I'm waiting to hear the gunshot.
You know what I mean?
I Dunno
inward then is up weird part too that I
as it also makes me feel good. Like wow,
I have a great relationship.
I mean I know we have a battles.
I know I've been a fucking idiot.
I've done everything I could to steer
it into the fucking fucking son.
But at the end of the day, I come home
with a chocolate chip cookie. I'd die.
Do what I gotta do. Right. So I
mean, I didn't know how the fuck,
what the hell was. I was back at
staples, don't back at staples.
And I'm looking at these
things. So I, and as always,
they get like one person at the register
and then one of the poor bastard who's
got to cover the whole fucking floor.
So I walk up there and I'm like looking
around, there's nobody to help me.
All they have is to shit on the floor.
I don't, there's no box I can grab.
It's in the back. So I just walk up
and I say to the lady at the register,
cause I see there's a guy with a two
wheeler helping somebody else with
something heavy and I
set it over his shoulder.
I was talking to the fucking
lady behind the register,
but he didn't realize that I go,
is anybody who can help me, uh,
get a file cabinet and without turning
around, he goes, I will help you sir,
when I'm done helping this customer.
So I immediately get it. The old
me would have been like, Hey,
first of all,
I wasn't talking to you and I understand
that you can't do two things at once.
All right? But I didn't, I
understood the whole fucking thing.
We said nothing to do with
him and nothing to do with me.
I guess I had to do with
me. You, I could've stepped
more to the side, you know,
had more of a, a straight on conversation
with the registered lady. But a,
I knew it was going on, this hit this,
this had, this came from corporate,
they will running as few
fucking people as possible.
This guy was having to do way too fucking
much for what he was getting paid for.
So that caused him to come at me the way
he was coming at me and I was coming at
them the way I was coming at them
cause I couldn't get any fucking help.
And in the end, the real concept created
a sitting on their Christmas yet.
So I let it go.
I just laughed or whatever.
And he came back and I made
a joke about how, you know,
he already have another five
guys out there helping them, um,
which relax the situation. So
now here we are, the two of us,
him having to cover way
too much square footage,
you know like a five on three and hockey
except it's the staples version of it,
you know, maybe like more like a
five on two if that was possible. So,
and there I am standing there trying to
pick out which file cabinet I want both
of us minutes just just
falling off of our lives.
And he got guys, so what's,
I guess I need this one here.
And I told him I go do, I can't believe
how depressing this system by this thing.
And he just started laughing and I
go, all right, so these look the same,
why is this one $50 more?
And he's like, all right,
that's a so and so.
They're known for making file cabinets,
they make the file cabinets and
that's just the staples version.
So I got all right, I start
pounding the file cabinet, you know,
listening to the sound hit,
neither one of them, you know,
trying to figure out which
one sounds more solid.
Obviously the guys that that's all
they do. There's sounds more solid.
Staples is trying to undercut
them being such douche bags.
They put this right next to it.
They make it the exact same color for
like 50 bucks less. Now I should say,
you know what,
fuck that file had cabinet people.
I should just save myself 50 bucks. But
that's not how I'm wired. I don't know why
I said fuck those staples cons like the
file cabinet people actually give a shit
about me.
I don't think they do.
But they give a shit enough to make a
fucking higher quality file cabinets.
So I go with that one. And uh, I dunno,
we wheel the fucking thing
out. I'm sitting there going,
can this fit in a Prius?
I have a truck. I didn't realize
I was going to buy this thing.
I was hoping it was
going to something else.
And I realized somewhere
between the fucking u two
song and the fucking boy band
that I had to buy a God damn file cabinet
and we'll laugh and we put the thing
in the back of the car. I tried to
tip him. He goes, no, no, no, no.
Cause this is what I do,
right.
The Guy who he's fucking won't
even take the Goddamn money.
So he leaves and I'm driving
this fucker thing home, you know,
feeling like that dude and the end of
the movie and last American Virgin when
this fucking chick cheats on them with
the dose should her up earlier and he's
driving away in the purple fucking station
wagon with the tear coming down his
eye. That's what I feel like. So a, I was
like, how can I turn this shit around?
So anyways,
they get back to the house or relative's
is still fucking sleep and I've got the
file cabinet, the back of the Prius. I'm
an old man, I got a bad back, you know,
but I got that German Irish blood. I'm
like, I'm, I'll fucking door myself.
I'll put it over my head. I'll open
the gate with my foot. Nall a slip,
another desk. And I was fine.
Like, you know what? Fuck this.
I'll wait till my cousin gets up.
That's all they say. Western mass.
Sometimes my cousin, um, I don't
even know if it's western mass.
I don't know where the fuck I heard
that in my travels. Uh, and I just said,
I'm just gonna fucking leave it there.
So I sit down and put it on
the TV and Lo and behold,
Lo and fuckable hold what's on television
as I put it on my favorite goddamn
show. All right, fast and loud.
The gas monkey garage guy.
So I'm sitting there
watching them and they,
everything they got to customize it and
all that type of shit. And you know what?
Okay,
I'm thinking about my stupid file cabinet.
How fucking cool their lives are,
their motorcycles and their awesome
cars and how they make everything look
fucking cool. And I was
like, you know what?
Why don't I have somebody fucking
paint this damn file cabinet.
I live in Los Angeles,
California.
We are hot riding hot rodding
allegedly started all,
they do the best interiors out here.
They do all these fucking great page jobs.
Why don't I get somebody,
it's fucking soul crushing
bandaid light brown.
It's even lighter than that. Throw a
little bit of cream in there just for you.
Lactose intolerant people didn't
make everybody puke on this podcast.
That's what it looks like.
So here's my question for you.
Does anybody know anybody
in the Los Angeles area?
Or I could bring a file cabinet over
there and they could paint it a color
that's gonna that's gonna make me
happy and I don't, I don't even need,
I don't need some fucking design.
Just put maybe the just m
m m m p on the side of it.
It's just something fucking
cool so I can look at it
and, and not just like, I mean, just
tap my shoulders slumped down like,
like that fucking quarterback for
the cowboys when he threw that last
interception against the eagles,
man.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Are the cowboys fans paying enough
for their five fucking Superbowls?
Good Lord. A buddy of mine texted me
God's team before that, before the,
uh, before the game started. And uh,
I don't know what you guys did to him
and how will you, will you guys too
arrogant after you last Superbowl win?
What did you do to take
out your 10 gallon hat?
Take a shit in it and fucking put it
over a Steelers fans head or something.
I don't know what the fuck
he did, but Jesus Christ. Um,
I, I've, I've, you know,
I was a cowboys fan, uh,
right up until they fired Tom Landry
and texture, texture. I'm left any fire,
Tom Landry.
And it went from this stoic,
we do things the right
way over here to he here.
How about them cowboys? Hey, wait,
it just got to fucking cartoony for me.
Um,
even though I like all, I like
everybody on that team. Um,
and I think I rooted for him
and all the Superbowls didn't,
I played the bills twice and then
they played the Steelers. Yeah,
I had to root for him against
the Steelers cause I lost money.
First fucking Superbowl I bet was 78 game.
Arguably the greatest
amass of talent ever.
When the cowboys played the Steelers
and lost to him, I lost 75 cents,
which was a lot of fucking money to me
in the fourth grade. It was, you know,
that was a hot lunch back then.
So anyways,
so here's the deal.
If you guys know anybody out here that
would do it, would take it off, you know,
and up and come and paint or something
like that. I have some ideas.
I definitely have some ideas, you
know, uh, of some shit I want done.
And I would probably be great
if I could give you a fucking,
just hit me up on Twitter
or hit me up on Facebook.
Send me a message or something
like that. Uh, I don't know.
Turn this fucking thing and just
something I want to look at.
I'll pay you top dollar. I don't give a
fuck. Just I have to have a file cabinet.
All right.
Let's see.
I don't know what else to do with
all the papers I'm supposed to pick.
Keep for these fucking God
damn people run and shit.
I just can't look at this
fucking thing anymore. All right.
I even left it in the box. Um, all right.
What else? Oh, speaking of that
fucking spare lain on the floor.
Um, bring this over here.
Somebody sent me this. Uh,
well how far into the podcast,
how are we 20 minutes in Jesus Christ.
Bill 20 minutes. You bitching about a file
cabinet? You fucking pussy. All right,
let's uh, let's, let's get the reads that
and we only got two this week. People,
two very special ones. All right,
number one out of the gate.
Dollar Shave Club. All
right. For a couple of,
for a couple of bucks a month,
she's right out of the gate.
That's like a false start. Let's
do that again. Dollar Shave Club,
every one for a couple of bucks a month.
A dollar shave club.com delivers amazing
quality razors right to your door.
Not only does it save you a ton of cash,
it saves you from trudging your sorry
ass down to the drug store for a pack of
blades. All right, I've talked to this
before. Always go there late at night.
They'll have one person working on the
floor. They're behind the register.
I got to wait till they get to the line
to go over and unlock the goddamn things
like they're made out of gold.
Um,
you don't have to deal with that at any
more because now with dollar shave club
for just a couple of bucks a month,
amazing quality razor blades are delivered
right to your door. That's right.
That is correct.
Thumbs up,
no more wasting time and no more getting
hit up the 20 bucks every time you buy
raises.
Everybody here is getting that dollar
shave club blades and you should too.
And here's a genius idea. Try replacing
your old shaving cream with doc dick.
Have is easy.
Shave Baba from dollar shave club.com.
Trust me, you've faced will thank
you. Later close. Oh, sorry.
What's supposed to read that? Here's the
big clothes everybody bought up. Boom. Uh,
don't waste time or to drug store
behind the lady paying at Penny's.
Go to dollar shave club.com.
Forward Slash poor, uh,
or go to [inaudible] dot com and
click on the dollar shave club banner.
Keep your stress level low and your
bank account Balance High Shave time,
shave money. Call it, go to dollar
shave club.com. Forward slash birth.
I literally had to close one of my eyes
to get through that without fucking up
anymore. Um, legal zoom.
Some things like starting a business
or protecting your family with a,
we'll aren't like, yeah, I just can't, I
just, I went blank in the middle of that.
There's too many words with ws. All right.
Start over again. Made me, me, me, me, me,
me. Legal, zoom.
Some things like starting a business
or protecting your family with a will
aren't like your others.
Knew other new year's resolutions.
You can't afford to blow them off.
I can fucking suck at this.
Fuck. All right. Number three,
take three on two.
Ready break, legal zoom.
Some things like starting a business
or protecting your family with the will
aren't like your others. New
written, so fucking difficult.
Legal Zoom,
everyone.
Some things like starting a business
or protecting your family with a will
aren't like your other
new year's resolutions.
You can't afford to blow them off. Instead
of less snacking and more exercise,
put them at the top of your list.
Uh,
legal zoom helps you incorporate
or form an LLC. What?
There's simple questionnaire starting
at just $99 over 1 million entrepreneurs
have done it and 90% of
customers recommend legal
zoom to friends and family.
You can also create a will starting at
just 69 bucks or even a living trust
quickly and easily get peace of mind
and protection. No surprise fees,
no hassles and no headaches.
Legal Zoom step by step process was
created by a team of experts in law and
technology.
Legal Zoom is not a law firm,
but you can but can connect you with a
third party attorney and provides you
with self help services from
wills to formations, trademarks,
powers of attorneys,
and more.
Go to legal zoom.com for even
more savings. Type in burpee.
You are our into the
referral box at the checkout.
Don't put off things you need to do.
Go to legal zoom.com now and use discount
code burpee. You are are. That's legal.
zoom.com discount code birth,
Jesus.
Fucking Greg Norman on
that one. Um, on Sunday.
All right, what am I talking about now?
Uh, what did I do this weekend? Well,
I did some sets around town getting ready
for my bucket list show at the Wiltern
theater and I got some new ones
for you. Sons of bitches. Oh,
do I got some new ones?
I was out last night.
I went down to the comedy store and I
got to run my set twice because they're
awesome.
They get like two,
three shows going at all times down at
the wonderful comedy store and they put
me up twice and I had a great time.
And um,
I was doing that all weekend.
I did take Saturday night off
because I wanted to watch that UFC,
UFC championship.
Um,
UFC one 68 Anderson silver
versus that other guy.
I still don't know his name.
I haven't even taken the time to learn
his fucking name because I was so
convinced that you know that he lost the
first one just because he was fucking
around and Ah, I shouldn't know the
champ's name here. Let me look this up.
Anderson Silva
Verse Chris Weidman. Hope I'm saying
that right. We've Weidman. I'm sorry.
All right. I thought the writing
was on the wall because, uh,
Matt, that terrorists Sarah was
in his camp and I'm like, Oh man,
that's like when he knocked out George
Saint Pierre and everyone's going,
all George didn't fucking train and
Yada, Yada Yada. And then then, uh,
Matt, the terrorists, Sarah was going and
let them eat or drink wine or whatever.
I thought it was hilarious, but he ended
up coming back and beating him. Um,
you know, I'm not trashing obviously
Matt Serra at all, but I'm just saying,
so I just thought that maybe this was
going to happen again because the first
time they had the fight,
like I've watched Roy Jones Jr like
make fun of people or clown them is the
youth says, I never seen it done
at the level of that first fight.
It was like fucking ridiculous.
Um,
and he ended up making a stupid face.
The guy punched him and knocked him
out. So it's like, all right, you know,
he's coming in this time and he's just,
he's going to handle this
business right as the youth sis.
How do I get all his fucking hip
hop shit in my, I don't even know.
I don't even listen to
this stuff. Um, so anyways,
maybe cause it's ruled the charts for 15
years, Bill and, and it is mainstream.
Maybe you heard it. It's staples.
You Red Cunt. Um, so anyway,
so I get this fight cause I want to see,
uh, the rematch to see if this Chris, uh,
we'd been a Weidman
guy's for real crushes.
It kills me that I don't know his fucking,
that I'm not pronouncing
his name correctly. Um,
okay.
But anyways, I wanted to see that. And
then also I wanted to watch that, uh,
that Ronda Rousey,
uh,
Mishna Tate fight cause
me and the lovely Nia,
we're watching the UFC fight club
fucking show the whole season.
And I gotta tell you, man, it was
an unbelievable night. Unbelievable,
unbelievable night of fights.
If you haven't ordered it yet,
it's totally worth the money.
And I had a bunch of people come over and,
uh,
we watched the fight and I'm
not, there's no sport. All right.
Spoiler alert if you, I don't know
if you live in under a fucking rock,
you weren't paying attention.
Uh,
Anderson Silver fucking
snapped his God damn leg.
Oh the second time this year I've seen it.
The Kid on Louisville and now
that it's just, it was not a,
it was not pretty, but I got to tell you
that and that the other dude Chris was,
was, was winning the fight at that
point. You know what I want to,
I want to ask Joe Rogan.
I got a call on his podcast because he
said something during that fight that I
thought was a really interesting,
where he said once you get knocked out,
you know,
you're never the same as far as your
ability to I guess take a punch like that
again. Like I, I don't,
I didn't quite understand it cause
that's not like you lose brain fluid.
It's still sitting in
the same amount of fluid,
but maybe I don't know what's going on.
So I wanted to ask him about that
because I found that really fascinating
because I remember Roy Jones
Jr no one could ever touch him.
And then he finally got knocked
out and after he got knocked out,
it seemed easier with each time to knock
them out and people were trying to say,
Oh, you know, uh, the, the,
the air of invincibility has gone and I
didn't think that. I just, it seemed like
something, there was something
different about them. I Dunno.
I found that really interesting.
So next time I run into him,
I'm definitely going to ask him about it.
I thought I had a lot to say about
that, that UFC shit. I guess I didn't,
I was just get blown away. How fucking
tough those guys are. You know, like,
I'll tell you one thing that
that guy who came in, the guy,
the lumberjack guy who was really in
bad shape for an ultimate fighter,
I,
we were sitting there watching and going,
this guy has the fucking torso
of like a regional manager.
If he didn't have that,
I will murder your whole family and
then sit down and eat soup afterwards.
Look on his face. One of the most
terrifying looks I've ever seen.
He came in like, not like, I'm going to
beat you. He's like, I'm going to like,
I was know he was going
to kill the other guy.
So they end up having their fight and uh,
all fucking awful torso takes a
knee to the head, drops to his legs,
grabs the other guys, drops to his
knees, grabs the other guy's legs.
And this guy range like,
I dunno for elbows and he must've been
using the perfect technique because when
they showed it in slow motion,
it was almost like this beginning of
a break dance move. It was very, uh,
fluid the way he was doing it with the
eye, with a little bit of Flair, you know,
it wasn't like, it was just bringing
it up like a jerk off like me. Like,
Heh, Heh, Heh.
It was like,
it was like this aerodynamic,
I don't know what he was doing.
I look fucking great.
He should have a little pinky out was,
it was like six of the classiest fucking
elbows to the side of the head I've
ever seen. And that was the end of that
lumber jack in any murderous thoughts.
He ever had had? Why is
my voice cracking? Um,
I dunno.
I always liked seeing that.
I love seeing when a guy goes into the
octagon and I just see the look on his
face and I feel whatever manhood I even
possess just drain out of me and just
see the other guy just lacrosse
ring like Ooh, that's a tough look.
You got there with gauge with gage
gage and then it's fucking over,
you know? Then you wish you could do
some something like that. You know,
maybe just some terrorist on a flight
and then you land the plane and they want
to give you the key to the city,
but you don't show up cause
you to fucking cool for it.
Anybody else just go on those
long fantasies like that? I do it.
I do it all the time. You know
what? I want to apologize for it.
I like living in my own little world,
tweed. My two years I in my two ears,
I am a hell of a fucking guy.
I'm a war veteran.
I'm a hero. I know how to fuck
well, I'm good at math. It just,
it's endless.
MMM.
Anybody watching any of
the NFL football yesterday?
Um, I actually went on a
hike yesterday, you know,
like the half a twinkle toes I m and a
with another buddy of mine just to make
it even a more homoerotic and uh,
I dunno, I wasn't interested in
any of the earlier fucking games
and plus I've been eating like shit,
you know,
with the holiday food and everything.
So I was like,
I gotta get out at least to try to walk
around a little bit so we decide when
you're going, what we're going
to go on this hike. And uh,
we just kept extending it and extending
it and extending it and I knew I was
going to pay the price for it. Long
story short, we get fucking lost.
We tried to cut down this one rich and it
just ended up getting so fucking steep.
Like, I was just like, if one of us
falls, um, I'm not saying we're, we're,
we're going to die from the fall,
but we're going to die from laying there
for four days until coyotes finally
find us and like just pick us apart.
You know,
as we try, if we were just
laying on our backs, you know,
making those noises you make as you're
trying to fight off jackals with a stick,
you know? Um, I would stab
myself with a stick. Personally,
I'd always take the coward way up,
how going to feel that wild animals
breath up against my ear lobes if it's
trying to get a better fucking lock on
my neck. I don't, I don't need that.
I don't need that. Um, Oh, speaking
of if some reason that made me feel,
think of Ronda Rousey has she just fucking
gradually got the arm bar going there.
Um,
people flipped out when she
didn't shake hands afterwards.
They were born the shit out of her.
I thought it was a great fight.
I'm a right if they don't
shake hands afterwards, hey,
how about after you
fucking break their arm?
You show a little bit of class and shake
the fucking arm that he didn't break.
It gives a fuck. You know
I liked it. I enjoyed it.
I liked that you did shake the heads.
What does that teach the kids?
What does that teach him?
You know what that done?
Punching their friend in the face
and then fucking snap and their arm.
Or if they don't get up and shake
their fucking quivering hand.
I liked it. I enjoyed it. Oh
the lovely Nia. Everybody.
She was going shush. Shush.
I have things to do. Are you
with your fancy shoes? That's it.
You look great. Thank you. Alright. Um,
anyways, the fuck was
I talking about? Yeah,
I enjoyed it and I didn't have a problem
that she didn't fucking shake your hand
up. I liked both fighters and
I wish him well. Oh look at me.
We get a goddamn doubled
the diplomat here. Anyways.
What the fuck was I just talking about?
Oh, it's talking about a NFL football
on another, the hike. That's right.
So we ended up getting lost when?
20 minutes in the wrong direction.
So those of you who are halfway decent in
math, it's a 40 minute fucking mistake.
And uh,
we were just laughing by the end,
we ended up being a four hour hike.
My buddy's like one of these dudes
who's like really into technology.
So with every hike he has something else.
You know,
I got an APP on my phone that
hell tell us how far we went.
He starts with that and then the next day,
yeah,
I got a bracelet that's measuring all
the calories I'm burning gave you some
sort of indicate it's like, cause
the fuck he gives a fuck. He's into,
he's into that ship. So, um,
okay.
I think at the hike ended
up being like 11 miles.
We like walked half a marathon and the
running joke was I was going to be back
in time for the one o'clock kickoff,
one o'clock out here for the pats game.
And it was every mistake we made,
I just kept saying like,
am I going to have to have
Nia tape the fucking game?
We ran out of water and um,
but you know,
we weren't near enough to civilization.
There was other hikers there in that
type of shit. But it was a, I dunno,
all I know is I ate like shit when I came
back and I still woke up today with a
flatter stomach than I had yesterday. That
is how far we hiked. And you know what?
Well what
people, that's the end of
my mediocre hiking story.
We're taking callers. Does anybody else
have a mediocre and hiking fucking story?
Um, all right, let's get to
some questions for this week.
I didn't talk about the Patriots game.
Um,
fucking great game could not finish off.
Uh,
should have lost the game if
the bills didn't, I dunno.
I Dunno what they were doing.
I actually tweeted in the,
the end of the third
quarter actually tweeted,
did the bills bet the Patriots?
And I got to tell you,
the amount of people who thought,
who read that is,
did the bills beat the Patriots?
And I got all these people.
Why don't you just look it up instead of
tweeting a bar? You Dom can't. So I get,
I got to write back to a bunch
of people going bet that beat.
I didn't say anything mean
I didn't trash them at all.
I just corrected them cause I knew that
that would hurt more. And you know me.
You know what I mean?
From Twitter's to fatties I'm all about
shaming cause that's how I was brought
up. Um, patriots bills, everybody, uh,
I don't know what to say about the
game other than it fucking rained.
I'm happy that we won another unbelievably
successful season for the Patriots.
I think Tom Brady had is arguably his
best season just considering what the fuck
he was working with now that the
defense route rose to the occasion.
But having said all of that,
I will be surprised if we win
more than one playoff game.
And I won't be surprised if we're
one and done just because, uh,
well the UFC is kind of weak, but I
dunno. It's a just, it's different.
It's different when it comes to January.
She probably gotta be asking yourself,
well then who you pick and bill you
staying with the fucking dirty birds out
there. The Seahawks, I guess.
Dirty birds of the Falcons? Yeah,
I think it's the Seahawks,
the loose,
it's huge that they got the home field
because for some reason I don't know why
they don't quite play as well on the road,
but they still ended up with what,
13 and three. I definitely think
at that it's theirs to lose. Um,
I dunno,
I was in Europe for fucking three weeks,
so I missed a lot of the football.
I can't really even talk intelligently
about who I think could beat them.
You know,
my buddy's saying the 40 niners that's
always a good pick to pick a division
rival cause they know each other so well.
Uh,
but I definitely think it's theirs to
lose and it would be nice to see them
finally win a Superbowl and give their
fans something to actually be loud about.
I know I've trashed a lot of the Seattle
fans for that dumb record, but I do,
you know what?
I didn't know.
It just annoyed me that your owner fucked
you so bad on those premium beers and
you guys busted him for it.
And then immediately he just gets back
in your good graces by just stroking your
fucking balls, taint and ass hole
with this loudest fans. Horseshit.
How much money did he make
off of that fucking beer?
Fucking you guys over as you sat there
screaming your fucking heads off,
you know that's all it takes.
A couple of trinkets,
little placard on the
wall and everybody goes.
Actually somebody said tonight that last
night I was talking to this other comic
and he was telling me how he likes the
pope and I like to pump like this guy.
He said, he's cool with atheist. You know,
they don't mind if gay people
get married and blah, blah, blah.
It's like that's because
they're hemorrhaging cash
in the fucking West. In the northern
hemisphere. It's a business.
They're only adding people down in
South America, but as far as up here,
they're fucked.
They're losing people day by day,
so they have to adjust
their message the same way.
When BP was involved in
that horrific oil spill,
all of a sudden now their logo is
painted in the color of grass and corn or
sunlight. Hey man, it's great they
care about the framing mia, that's,
that's,
that's what the Seahawks owner did.
He was doing that boss Hog shit and you
guys caught them or somebody caught him.
I got to give you guys the link to
that video. They had the thing right?
They had the tall beer, the premium
fucking bear, the cost more.
And then they had the short fat one and
somebody finally sucked down a short fat
one and then poured the tall one into the
short fat one is the exact same amount
of ounces. They didn't have the
decency to make it two ounces more.
So it kind of spilled over
and that would have ended it.
They was so fucking cheap.
I'm going to halfway through this and
I'm forgetting if the actually was the
Seahawks owner, but I'm too
far. I'm in too deep now. I
just gotta go with the lie.
Maybe it's the truth. That's what
they did. So what does he do?
He starts getting fucking
former celebrities,
people from top gun to come up there
and ring that bell to get the 12th man
thing going.
He just stroked your fucking
balls and you bought into what?
He's not your friend. All
right. And having said all that,
I hope you guys won a championship
because I like to see hawks way back, uh,
when they had Jim Zorn and Steve
Largent, David, Greg, Kurt Warner.
I liked those teams. Um, I absolutely, I'm
not being a Douche share. I don't mind.
You knew they were one of the few teams
that had a nice uniform and actually was
sort of a lateral move. But
I liked the older ones. Man.
I like that silver helmet.
I thought it was fucking
cool. Um, all right.
Enough with my half ass.
Okay.
Half ass fucking NFL talk. Uh, I am
going to the pro bowl again this year.
People in this time, I'm hoping
I'm going to make it. Um,
last year I ended up getting some active
work, but it was uh, was actually, oh,
I never told you guys this story.
It's my blues.
The final episode I got to do on a
breaking bad and I won't ruin it because I
know people are watching the thing,
but it's basically it's a scene in the,
well,
you know what it is because you'll watch
the last half of the fifth episode and
you'll see the last one.
I'm in that scene where I'm sitting in
the car with those two other characters.
Um,
that was,
I had a gig Saturday night in Honolulu.
Um,
and then the next day me and Jay law
had Rosebowl legend and one of the,
uh, comedians on the show
tomorrow night at the Wiltern. Um,
we did the show and then the next day
we were going to go to the pro bowl.
And uh,
okay.
I Dunno,
there's this running joke in show
business that if you want a book
acting work, you know, books,
some sort of vacation book,
some sort of fun.
Because if you're sitting
there watching the phone,
like you will not work for 10 years.
But if you go, you know what, fuck this,
I'm going to go, I'm gonna
go, I'm gonna go. I Dunno.
We're going to go on a fucking vacation.
I don't know what money you'd go with
if you weren't getting act and work,
but whatever. Do you
just plan something? Hey,
me and my boys are going to
go to this game immediately.
You're getting acting work.
So it's kind of, it's kind
of a good thing. But uh, mmm.
So anyways,
I had to,
I did the Gig and then I literally had
to fly back to la the very next day and
then from La to Albuquerque,
New Mexico,
and then we were the
first one out of the gate.
That's why I couldn't go to the game.
I remember that. We shot that scene.
It like a,
okay.
God, what was it? I think the call
time was like five in the morning,
five in the morning.
And I think we started shooting at
six and we were done by like six 30.
Like that was the thing about
when you did that show was the,
everybody was so god damn good.
MMM.
They just had the coverage.
They had the dialogue,
they just had it down and uh, I
dunno, they made you look great.
So all I did was just make sure
I always knew my lines. No,
you fucking lines say what they wrote.
Hit your mark and they're going
to make you look great. And uh,
the other two guys were regulars,
so they were an awesome so they
know what the fuck they were doing.
So we are in and out of there and like he
had an eye. There were like 30 minutes.
Oh, back to back. Mediocre
Story. I'm fucking crushing it.
Just slapping signals to the opposite
field. Hitting for average here, people.
Um, anyways. All right,
so let's, let's go here. All right,
let's, let's read some of the letters,
some of the letters.
How come there's not a new year song?
I feel like singing this week and then
all areas is that awful one awful fucking
won. What is that? How's it going? Hey,
he's a jolly good fellow,
right? Is that how it goes?
Shut all the acquaintance be
forgot and never abroad to ma.
I never understood what that meant.
I don't know what all anxiety means.
It's just a sad fucking,
I had grapes of Wrath kind
of shit. Just, you know,
I just feel like I'm in the dust bowl
when I sing that fucking song. It's just,
it's not a happy song. Ah, Jesus. Bill,
Jesus Christ. Who pissed in your cheerios?
Um, all right. Newsletter pay bill.
Do you have a newsletter to let me know
when you'll be live in the south again?
Um, I announced him on this
podcast and I, I announced it, uh,
via Twitter and Facebook or whatever.
That's basically how I do it.
Speaking of which,
uh,
we have almost got all the dates for the
Canadian tour lined up and I'll let you
know I'm going to some
fucking places that a,
I never thought I'd so it's
not just a hockey cities.
I'm also going to other ones just to get
your Canadian hopes up that you're not
going to have to drive over
to another province. Um,
I probably shouldn't have done that,
but uh, there's definitely some, uh,
some pretty fucking
that's going to be fun.
It's going to be fun and I'm
bringing my hockey stuff up there.
I'm going to figure out where there's
a pond hockey game or someplace where I
can play and I want to go up
there and get embarrassed.
I want you people up there in Canada did
show me once and for all that it is in
fact your game. Okay. Um, I don't know.
I'm going to figure out that I want to
do that and I want to get drunk and do
some curling and I, I feel like my
time up there will be a complete,
okay, I want to do that and I
want you to help me do that.
So next week,
but then the week I'm going to announce
the dates for the Canadian tour and um,
or at least to cities and then I don't,
the reason why I don't do it
is because then people go to,
is there a link and then there's not a
link. Well, when is it going to be a link?
I just like to fucking put it out there
when I have all the information. Like,
Hey, I'm coming to Canada. I can tell
you this. It is going to be in March.
All right. There you go. All right,
here we go. Okay. Friends, cheating.
Wife a there.
Billy bad AI is a longtime fan. Love
your comedy. Thank you very much.
Uh,
I'm currently in the air force and one
of my coworker's wife is a total slut.
Now wait a minute. Let's see what she's
done here. My wife and his wife friends.
Oh wait. My wife and his
wife's friends are friends,
so she shares a lot of details with her.
She's sleeping with numerous guys on
base and a couple of guys in our work
section. Oh No. And she's
telling your wife about it.
What she wants to get caught?
Uh,
the messed up thing is that he knows
all the guys that she's messing around
with. In the past, my
coworker was a real dog,
but he's cleaned up his
act since getting married.
He did all his dirt before
marriage or before marriage.
But she sees this as a
payback. Oh. Oh, well.
What the fuck that they never
should have gotten married.
Yeah.
I mean, I'm not going to judge
anybody in the store. You know,
they have it for the grace of God. Go
I, I was a piece of shit, you know,
but they,
they shouldn't have gotten married.
Okay.
He did all his dirt before marriage,
but sees this is payback and even told
my wife that she only married him for the
benefits.
Okay.
Yeah. Well, what are you going
to do? This thing was, uh,
this was built in sand with
some toxic waste in it.
It's so crazy that one of the married guys
she's sleeping with, sat at the table,
the same table with us during
our annual Christmas party.
That's not the bad part.
They have two children together.
Every time we deploy for six months,
she brings the guys to their house.
Wow.
Dragging the kids into it.
Okay.
Oh right. She went Jordan on
that. She just took the fucking,
she should change the game there.
I'm leaving this base soon and I
feel that I should say something,
if not directly, maybe indirectly,
to help him figure it out himself.
What do you, what do you
think? Maybe you think,
yeah,
maybe you think about
making a stop in Guam. Oh,
you went the other way. Okay. Uh,
I'll be there for the next three months
and I know that you'd kill with the
military community. Do what?
I'd fucking go to Guam.
It's not from the Spanish
American war there. Um,
uh, Jesus Christ. So obviously he was
fucking around before they got married
and now, oh, now he's stopped.
Okay.
This is a,
this is a friend of yours.
Uh,
I'm currently air force and one was my
coworker's wife, so he's a coworker.
All right, well, let's see.
I think this is up to you if you want
to get involved in this thing. Um,
I dunno how about anonymous letter?
No,
I don't do that because then
he's trying to think who knows?
And who doesn't know? I Dunno, Dude.
I don't know how to cross that one.
Um,
yeah,
tell him I don't know. We'll
look at, you know what,
it's hard to have sympathy for them.
I mean, you can't sit there and uh,
do that to somebody and think they're
not going to do it back to you.
I've learned all the lessons in this
fucking story and my horrific fucking
single life. So, uh, I got, you know,
sorry,
how do I tell this one?
Okay.
I knew a guy, I know a bloke. No, no,
it was a bloke and now a bloke that uh,
how do I say this?
He was going to get married to this girl
and he knew that she was fucking around
on him and he went and told the dude
and the dude didn't believe him and then
got mad at him and then
stopped being friends with him.
And then he went on and had two kids
and she continued to fuck around and 10
years later he's paying alimony
and child support. So, um,
it all depends on your piece of mind.
I mean,
this guy is in front of you is what
the fuck? Just say like, look, dude,
we're not friends. I'm leaving.
I don't have a dog in this fight.
I just feel like he should know. I
guess that that's what I would do. Uh,
you should do it.
You should do it for the fucking kids.
Good Lord. Good Lord. Good Lord.
Those kids are going to be fucked up.
They're already fucked up.
It's over.
So Jesus Christ,
if they would dogs, they put them all down
in the street. They're all [inaudible].
They all got rabies at this point.
Terrible, terrible, terrible things.
Terrible things are done. Jesus Christ.
That was a horrible fucking story.
A burst doc, whatever
that means. Bergen stock,
um, long time. Uh, Billy
freedom trail. Longtime Fan.
I was wondering to myself the other day,
how much longer until we
get a bill burr event,
some type of festival and event.
Well,
you're the ring master
and master of ceremonies.
You could host pie eating contest.
I'd make the fucking pies a judge,
a beauty pageant,
actually a pie eating contest.
They don't really make good pies,
do they? They just sort of bullshit.
You just eat out the filling a judge,
a beauty pageant and cut a ribbon with
the novelty size. Pair scissors. Do to,
if I could judge a pig too, I would
do this. You set it up. I'll do it.
Vendors will sell Turkey legs,
cotton candy and fried dough.
Babies will get their faces painted.
Uh,
and while you're not hosting an event,
you'll be walking around the grounds in
a seersucker suit. Dude, I'm fucking in.
You'll probably say something about
not many people coming up for it.
That's not true. A few thousand
people would come out. Uh, Liz Walker.
We'll cover it on the six o'clock news
and the following year there'll be 10,000
people will fly in from lots of places.
If they get enough notice.
Don't bother explaining
why this is a bad idea.
Every one of your listeners is
adding up their vacation days. Dude,
this is fucking, you know what? I
don't know if I want to host it,
but I want to go to it.
I want to go there with this though.
I want to go to something
with his fucking a prize pig.
That's what people are fighting for.
Yeah,
I would do that in a
second, sir. You set it up.
You set it up and I would
change and I would bring in,
uh, what else would I have?
Okay.
He needs some sort of music.
You know what,
I bring more in like street performance.
I know a couple of them from
back in the day in my, uh,
when I was living in New York,
it was a couple of guys that I knew that
were fucking great and I actually did a
comedy show and I had one of them come
down and perform and uh, he crushed it.
I'd add that element to it.
So what you do with this is what you do.
You have a little backward shit going on.
You do it in the backwoods.
So all the backwoods people show up.
But then you know,
what about the people who live
in the backwoods and there,
but they were into shit
beyond the back woods.
That's when you bring in the street
performers from New York. Right.
So people think that even though it's
down home, it's also a little dope.
Is that the kids used to say
that are now older than me. Um,
okay.
I would do something like that.
I,
any of that shit that's
considered fucking, uh,
I dunno what it's considered.
It's looked down upon by a lot of
people out here in Hollywood. You know,
who think that you know,
those debts,
they'll fly over state stuff and that
there are a cut above because they write
jokes for four camera shoot sitcoms,
um,
with next door neighbors.
Um,
I like all that shit.
Yeah.
Do it. Set it up. You get the
ball rolling. I'll fucking do it.
Throwing some fucking some sort
of car. Show a prize pig. Right?
There's gotta be some sort of blue ribbon,
one for a farm animal. I already know.
There's like a zillion of these things.
Just tell me where to go. I want,
I want to go to one of these things.
Do I get to shoot a fucking gun? Hey,
by the way, I just saw, um, somebody
recommended this last night.
I just watched a bobcat Goldthwait
bobcat Goldthwait can't even talk today.
Yeah. Made this movie called
God bless America. Uh,
I'm going to go out on a limb and
say that it's a dark comedy. Uh,
it's on Netflix.
Check it out.
I'm still working my way through
the first season of the killing.
Just giving these people off free.
Fucking Nah, what do you call it?
Shout outs here. You know I do
this because then you guys go, oh,
we should check this out. You should
check this up. Um, you know, I actually,
somebody told me a book I should order
and I ordered the fucking thing and it
never, it never showed up. I
ordered shit and it doesn't show up.
I think I don't hit the
complete the deal button,
but what do you, there's no
store to go to. It's fucking
genius. I don't even know.
Where is amazon.com based out of,
where is that store?
Is that information exist? We're
in. They do buy. There's no taxes.
Everything's free. And
it is wonderful. Oprah.
Turn your fucking head to the left
and see the tent city on the horizon.
All right. Yeah, I would
do that. I would do that.
I would go to a Rodeo. I do any of that
shit. All right. Girlfriend hates you.
Well, she should, uh, deal dear Burbank.
Read slowly buddy.
I know you can do it.
Yeah,
he wrote it in all capital letters to ah,
your ball busting content.
That was a funny one. It's not too old one
is it? Holy Shit. Where did the day go?
Um, all right. All right. Travel
all over the country as you do.
Except I don't do it to make people laugh.
I do it so my current boss can
make money anyway. Lately I've,
lately I've been listening to your podcast
and my truck and my girlfriend can't
stand it. She literally hates your
guts simply because you curse.
What the fuck?
Uh,
we ended up making deals where we
listened to 10 minutes of Bullshit Beyonce
than 10 minutes of your podcast.
God Damn it.
I tried to tell her that your podcasts
make my day and that you are hilarious
and generally a good guy,
but she totally disagrees.
Can you tell her a few things
that you do that are nice, uh,
besides the fact that you make
people laugh for a living,
which should be enough.
No, it shouldn't cause I get paid
for the uh, like charity work,
going to the make a wish
foundation or whatever. Fuck.
Let her know you aren't a conch,
even though you are much love from
your Canadian friend, Ole, Ole, Ole,
Ole. He wrote, Oh, first of all,
sir,
I don't need your girlfriends approval.
I don't give a shit what she thinks
about me. Breach for a wrist.
Make sure she doesn't shut
this off. Okay. Hey Lady,
look what you're doing to the man
in your life right now. You make it.
I'm so fucking miserable. He enjoys this
podcast. He likes that I fucking curse.
He likes it.
Can you just have that?
Yeah.
What's worse?
In all honesty,
the Horse Shit that I do on this
thing or listen to somebody say,
I don't think you're ready for this jelly.
You know,
at least I'd take the piss out of myself.
Every podcast.
I don't walk around like some arrogant
ass talking about how fucking great I am
and all this shit I have. Does she do
that? I don't even know how she does it.
I don't want to listen to her stuff.
Um, you know, least I fucking,
I go in one direction.
I don't come up with something that's
funny and then or whatever. Interesting.
And let's say 50 times in a fucking
row do I? It'd be lagging a bad.
It'd be like they made better
ring or 20 minutes fucking later.
[inaudible] or else what?
You're going to go suck another dick
if I don't give you something shiny,
like just gimme something shiny right now
or I'm going to go blow somebody else.
Hey Lady,
start walking.
Okay.
Go do that little mind walk like you're
going down a fucking escalator right
down to the dude's Dick next to you.
I don't give a shit like this country.
I don't respond to threats. Okay?
Actually we do, but not terrorist threats.
I don't respond to that.
Okay?
Okay.
Listen, first of all, if
I sat here and listed,
you don't do nice shit to tell
people you're doing nice shit. Okay?
Isn't that in the Bible? Hayden's pray
in public. Ooh, look out holy we are.
Look what the fuck we're doing. If
you're lady thinks all I do is bad shit,
I don't give a fuck.
Okay.
Okay,
good Lord.
What kind of world that you live in it,
you're driving a truck
and you listen to Beyonce.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
I, I gotta be honest with you. I,
I can't watch performers who don't seem
like at any like date they have this
look on their fucking face that did just,
they can't even believe how
fucking amazing they are
at that point in the crowd.
I'm just like, well, you don't need me.
Okay.
Yeah. Yeah. Look, you know,
that's like when these fucking people
like they score touchdowns or they've day
the athletes,
right.
They fucking dunk balls and do this shit
and they start thumping their fucking
chest.
Okay.
I can't match that energy.
Yeah.
Pau Gasol
dunking a ball or whatever it
does a lay up and that goes right.
Ah,
like you're in 300, you know, I'm not
disrespecting their level of athleticism,
but you put a ball through a fucking hope.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Punching your own chest.
Did deuce chills. All
right. A lot of that left,
that type of shit. I can't
get it to, you know, my Jay Z.
I really enjoy Jay z. But at
some point you're like, I get it.
You have a lot of stuff.
Your life is amazing.
I could never hope to have a life as
amazing as yours because you are that
amazing.
Please by all means.
Tell me about your next big purchase.
Um, yeah, so dude, I don't give a fuck.
I don't give a fuck whether
you're, you're, you're, you're
a woman likes me or not.
Um, if a woman's listening right
now, you're a selfish dose. Okay?
Okay.
Does he sit there going off on
Beyonce? Maybe he does. I don't know.
Maybe the two of you just need to
have a little more respect for, uh,
your playlist. Okay.
They do make headphones.
Why don't you put the fucking
headphones on and listen to Beyonce?
Why he's driving the truck. He can't
have headphones on. That's illegal.
And then you could listen to her,
you know,
making a financial deals for her
vaginal area. Uh, New Year's,
everybody. Here we go.
Dear Billy Ball drop.
Okay.
Not going to ask you what you're doing
on New Year's cause I already know you
and your Rosebowl crew will be tap
dancing at the Wilton over there. Uh,
I'm going to be there with
the girl. I'm 50% into. Okay,
well then that affects, uh,
what you should be buying
her that night. And he goes,
she's cool, she's hot and I don't
have any major complaints about her.
I'm also not in love with her and really
can't see anything beyond hooking up.
My plan is to laugh my ass off and see
what happens. All right, if we hook up,
that's great. If not, no big deal, dude.
You're in the zone. You're in the zone.
This is some demand shit. You don't
care if she comes, stays laser praise.
Now you got the head dude. Um, I don't,
I told two friends and they boast,
advised against talking up with her.
All right, well, I don't know your friends
and I don't know what their motive is.
Let's see if you explained this.
Here he goes,
I would never let that decide
whether or not I would.
But the interesting thing is that they
both said independent of each other,
that hooking up with a girl
on New Year's Eve, Mike,
give her the wrong impression and that
she's going to be a leach afterwards. Oh,
that's fucking, that's just
fear mongering. That's bullshit.
What does your finger
on as the ball drops,
all of a sudden you have a relationship.
They had a good time at some labs,
so like you don't to go to the
farmer's market. No, I don't.
Do you have something against farmers
markets? Not really who they are.
Why didn't you where to go?
Because you know I don't,
I don't feel like going with you.
I don't feel like the spark your fucking
ass off for what being honest I have.
Fuck you there. It's, it's the end of
the relationship. Anyways, he goes,
I can't even fathom why New Year's Eve
would be be considered a special occasion
that would lead to her thinking that this
whole topic is ridiculous and I can't
even stand to waste time talking about it,
but I wanted to hear your opinion.
I think I just gave it to you. My question
to you is, do you agree with that?
And also,
do you think there are any days on the
calendar that would make a girl think you
were into her? Oh yeah. If you
took around on Valentine's Day.
Yeah, it's about it. Valentine's Day.
Okay.
Valentine's Day that that would be it.
What else? What other
day? Saint Patrick's Day.
Okay.
You know, you sit in there eating
a fucking meat pie next door.
It hammered out of your mind
with a green plastic hat on.
I think he really likes me.
Um, the key and if I could,
if I could do my single life
over again is I would have been
way less fearful to be honest.
You know,
when relationships were starting,
you know,
uh,
women are not as
okay.
Psycho is, you think, I mean, a lot of
times when you say that women are psycho,
it's because you were being
deceptive and a, yeah.
Then they go fucking psycho.
Yeah, they definitely do. But you,
a lot of times creative.
If you just tell them straight up front
when they're like, so what is this?
And just be like,
look,
I'm not looking to get in a
relationship right now or like, listen,
I enjoy your company, but I'm not
feeling like this spark like this,
something to that next level.
I just feel like you should know that
and you'll be surprised at how well they
take that. You know, they,
it's not that always, you know,
if you say that the second you feel it,
it's usually pretty early on.
So there's no really deep feelings and
that's all people just don't want to get
hurt. Okay. And believe me, I heard
a lot of fucking people believe me.
And um, so that's what I
learned. I remember one, um,
Jesus Christ years ago
and I was at just a
lad living in New York.
Yeah.
I remember I hooked up with this, this
woman, and she was just like, you know,
so what is this? Where's this going? And
I was just like, uh, nowhere. I'm like,
fucking 1235. She was 23. I'm like,
I'm like 12 years older than you,
you know, by the time you took 30,
I'm going to be like 60.
What do you think it's going?
She actually laughed and I was just
like, you know, she goes, so what are
we doing? But just
hanging out, having fun.
So whatever crazy thing you want to try,
but you don't want to do it with
your husband. Do it with make
and that was it. And she was
just like, all right, cool.
We had fun for a few weeks and then that
was fucking hit and nobody got hurt and
uh, you know, lost touch with her
and that was it. No harm, no foul.
Had a great fucking time. So
there's no light, but look,
you take them out on Valentine's Day
and you get them a rose and all of that
shit, you start leading them on.
So what you're really talking to,
I feel is you're talking to two
younger guys like me probably at that,
like meet like how I was, I mean,
how am I trying to say this?
You're talking to two guys who
had their age right now. I,
their skill level was what my skill level
was where they don't know how to set
it up. So they're sitting
there going, oh, don't do this.
Don't bring them out on this day.
Cause that makes them this. Um,
all that says to me is that they don't
know how to communicate what's going on.
So they feel like they,
and they're also in that thing where
they feel like they have to fucking throw
their jacket over a mud puddle and let
them walk on it in order to get fucked
that night.
Which you don't,
you just have to be honest because women
enjoy sex too and they also enjoy you
telling them what the fucking deal
is. All right, so there you go.
So you don't have anything to worry about.
Just don't give her a card saying I love
you. I know. How many kids do you want?
I want to meet your parents.
Just don't do that shit.
I'm feeling like you have to say that
shit to them. All right. You know what?
Just look the fact that you've, you, you
know that those guys are full of Shit.
I don't need to keep going on with
this and it's already past fucking two
o'clock here. So I've got to
get this podcast uploaded. Um,
that's a podcast for this week. Happy
new year, everybody. Once again,
thank you so much to everyone who
came out to my shows this year,
it really was the best year of standup
I had, had the most fun on stage.
I got to go to the most places,
perform to the all kinds of people.
It was absolutely phenomenal
year for me and, uh,
can't do it without you guys
showing up and thanks to you,
to everybody who writes into the podcast,
listens to it and all that. All right.
Given thanks like it's thanksgiving,
but it's fucking new years. All right,
so get out there.
Okay.
Paced your drinking. Pick
your target early, close in.
Make her laugh. Okay. Take
it down before 10 o'clock.
There you go. Happy New Year. Go Fuck
Yourself. I'll talk to you next year.